الى تطورات في السودان حيث افاد مراسل
الجزيره بسماع اطلاق نار متقطع وتحليق
للطيران جنوبي مدينه ام درمان جاء ذلك بعد
ساعات من بدء سريان اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وهو الاول
الذي سيخضع لمراقبه وسطاء التفاوض جديد
الاوضاع نتابعها عبر الهاتف من جنوبي
الخرطوم مع مراسلنا الطاهره المرضي الطاهر
نعم في هذه اللحظات او خلال ساعات الماضيه
نشهد هدوء في العاصمه المثلثه الا اننا
يعني نلاحظ بعض يعني اعمل الدخان على مكان
بعيد شمال الخرطوم ولكن يبدو ان الهدنه
تطبق بشكل الى درجه ما حافظ على الهدوء
خلال هذه الساعات خلال ساعات النهار ويبدو
ان هذه الهدنه تختلف عن سابقاتها بكونها
فيها ليله مراقبه تشترك فيها الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه وكذلك ممثلين للجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى
ان الجيش السوداني اضرب بيانا وقال انه
سيلتزم بهذه الهدنه التي وقع عليها في جده
وكذلك قوات الدعم السريعه اعلنت هذا
الالتزام اذا نحن يمكننا القول بان هذه
الهدنه في يومها الاول عدا بعض يعني
الاصوات الرصاصه التي سمعناها نقول ان
هنالك هدنه يعني بدت تظهر يعني كما نشاهد
برضو ايضا على الطرقات تحركات السيارات
محاوله الاستفاده منها بالنسبه للمواطنين
لجلب الكثير من احتياجاتهم الغذائيه او في
مجال الجوانب الصحيه ويتطلع المواطنه
تكتمل شروط هذه الهدنه المتعلقه بابعاد
المظاهر العسكريه من المستشفيات التي خرجت
عنها للخدمه
الاشتباكات والقذف الذي اطالها في الفترات
السابقه واصلاح ايضا كذلك الجوانب
المتعلقه بالخدمات سواء كان المياه
وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي ما يزال التيار
الكهربائي ينقطع على بعض المواقع بالاضافه
الى ان المواطن يريد ان يرى ايضا الخدمات
اضافيه خاصه المساعدات التي بدا يتحدث
عنها وتتحدث عنها الامم المتحده تتحدث
عنها وزاره الصحه بان هنالك مساعده
انسانيه وصلت الى بورت سودان وفي طريقها
الى الخرطوم ولكن ان الدخول كان صعبا ولكن
في ظل هذه الهدنه لربما تكون هنالك فرصه
سانحه لادخال هذه المساعدات خاصه
المساعدات الطبيه وغيرها في المواطن
يحتاجها بشكل كبير بالاضافه الى ان هذه
الهدنه لربما تخدم كما اعلنت الامم
المتحده اكثر من مليون شخص بين نازح ولاجي
وانتصر هذه المساعدات الى عدد كبير من
هؤلاء ايضا هنالك تفاؤل من الذهب
والمنظمات الوطني والاقليمي التي رحبت
بهذه الهدنه واعتبرتها بدايه جيده ليمكن
ان تؤسس لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار وحلل
الازمه بشكل
حوار يمكن ان يفضي الى حل الازمه بشكل
كبير الطهر المرضي من جنوبي الخرطوم شكرا
جزيلا لك